à 23 ans taina défilé statistiques
elle a commencé sa formation à
l'institut de tourisme et d'hôtellerie
du québec en pleine pandémie et elle est
convaincue d'être sur la bonne voie je
pense qu'avoir faire un choix judicieux
d'avoir profité de ce cette pente en
déclin pour pouvoir regagner dès que je
serai fraîchement diplômés pourtant ils
sont de moins en moins nombreux à
envisager une carrière en tourisme et en
restauration
le tram qui compile les données pour 32
établissements d'enseignement collégial
confirme une baisse d'inscriptions dans
le domaine non plus cinq armes c'est un
domaine qui était un ralentissement au
niveau de l'intérêt mais la chute s'est
accélérée dramatiquement cette année
pour les techniques en tourisme les
demandes ont baissé au 1er tour de
presque 40% en gestion hôtelière la
baisse est de 26% en gestion
d'établissements de restauration la
diminution est de près de 15% pour 2021
c'est ce contexte actuel le secteur du
tourisme aux audi ce secteur qui a été
le plus touché un secteur où le manque
de main-d'oeuvre existait avant que tout
éclate
ajoutons la baisse d'inscriptions et
ceux qui se sont réorientés pendant la
crise si ce concert beau faire une
catastrophe si on ne se met pas tous
ensemble a poussé là sur une relance
très très forte et relance il y aura
même si on ignore quand et comment elle
se fera les gens sur la paire la nuit
qu'ils auront vécu en confinement ou
barricadé à la maison or neuf rock à
croire sachant qu'on véhicule à volonté
le voyage et il y aura un retour des
voyageurs internationaux s'était
entrevoit un essor spectaculaire post
pandémie je suis convaincu et tout le
monde est convaincu
même mes collègues étudiants ou mes
collègues travailleurs sont convaincus
que ça va être des années folles et ça
va être beau alors que 2019 avait été
une année record pour le tourisme il
avait aussi mauvaise presse
on parlait tourisme de masse empreinte
environnementale la reprise graduelle
sera donc l'occasion d'imposer une
nouvelle vision
tout le monde est dans cette réflexion
là c'est pour ça que 12 qu'on dit c'est
que ça va prendre des spécialistes en
touriste l'engouement pour les carrières
en tourisme pourrait donc reprendre
selon cet expert vous opportunité de
venir nombreuse dépasse un retour de
balancier issigeac oudry charbonneau
raid au canada mon frère